that's another stuff actually I wanted
to I was realizing like a lot of you
guys why are you here there's like over
3,000 people in this room why are you
here like it's Thursday like shouldn't
you be at school or work or something
that some people are even like
celebrating things like did did anybody
does anybody have like a birthday that
just happened like within the last week
or have a birthday coming up the next
week any birthday's winds your birthday
your birthday's tomorrow your birthday's
today what's your name
Danny do you want to come up and help me
oh I got a gift for you your birthday's
tomorrow your birthday would you help me
- can I give you a gift I got a gift for
you guys actually can one of the
enforcers help them get back here so
they don't die climbing up on the stage
there's I say yeah so go - they'll help
you up so I brought a couple of gifts
let me get this set up
actually thank you oh yeah there's a
mark
perfect thanks I just realized something
I only have one wrapped gift it's okay
we'll fix this we'll fix this come on
out what's your name dark shell nice to
meet you um and what's your name Danny
nice to meet you dark shell um would you
mind coming over here this is your gift
and would you are you cool having a seat
would you mind helping me out for a few
minutes I want you to hold this and I'm
gonna I don't have a gift for him so I'm
gonna do something else and but if you
hold on to that I'll ask you to help us
with what we're doing over here in a
second Danny right you know what I can
do
yeah hey boy do you have the box of more
can you climb what this is my son he's
also can you give him a copy so what
he's got is a box of a new tabletop game
which is literally the first tabletop
game that's ever been made with the
borderlands franchise and it's called
Borderlands tiny Tina's robot tea party
yeah you know what just set those you
can just sit this Thanks oh and this is
my son Randy he's Randy three I'm not
that vain if I was the first I probably
wouldn't have done it but I'm just
keeping it going you know but I think
he's actually going to be there's a
booth where this game you can can you
rip that open actually I'll get you a
boxer I'll give me a freshman we're
gonna destroy that one because I want to
show people what's up there's a booth on
the floor if you want to pick one up
it's like 20 bucks
booth twenty-four one one yeah open it
up and
my kid will actually be there and his
name's Randy Pitchford
so he'll be helping to sell games so if
you want you can go pick one up and you
can get it signed by randy pitchford
so ok so here actually let's use this
table here what do we got and get those
out let me show you it so here's the
instructions this is actually the firt
like these get just got shipped here
this game isn't even out yet so it's
kind of like a PAX East exclusive see
objective be the first to finish your
claptrap by building two arms a hat and
a wheel of a single claptrap oh this is
cute like tiny Tina's like written
she's like scribbled over the rules
she's I don't know if you can see that
but she's uh she's written that's funny
yeah branding branding Brent yeah yeah
so yeah can you open the cards up so the
card game I'll help you I'm good with
cards okay so here hold that oh you know
what else you guys want to buy this
because under here there's a shift code
it's like an Easter Egg okay we'll come
back to that so what you get is you
first pick a claptrap like their
standard claptrap like gentlemen
claptrap there Sheriff pirate wizard and
you're gonna build your claptrap and so
you'll get a hand of cards and there's
all kinds of different cards like okay
so this is the regular claptrap he's got
his birthday hat there's this is a
wizard arm alright so you take all these
parts there's the sheriff wheels sheriff
hat
gentleman claptrap hat wizard hat and so
on oh this one isn't one the special
cards this is gonna take a spin so with
take a spin you get to pick the next
seven cards look at them pick the one
you like and then you can immediately
put it on your robot you can also put
the wrong parts on other robots so you
can screw your neighbors there's usually
on the bottom there's ways to fix that
yeah like right here swipe you can hold
those so a swipe take a card at random
from another player's hand
Oh party foul this is Tina's party foul
sometimes you need to interrupt
somebody's going to make the winning
move you can block them stop a card from
being played the sheriff arm oh bring
the pain so punch this is this is bricks
punch he can punch like the legs off a
class wrap which I've always wanted to
see happen new you if everybody's just
been dogpiling on you and just
completely screwed your robot up you can
reset it you can knock all the pieces
off and get a new you wild
did you struct the digit start card is
all the digits truck cards are wild so
you can apply it even if it doesn't
match your coffee shop dumpster dive
that's crazy Earl you can go through the
discard pile and pick whatever card you
want pirate hat there's a bunch of these
but I just realized something I have
cards and I'm and I'm a magician
should we should we do a trick with this
yeah oh you wanted you want to do a
trick with me okay
so here's what I'll do I'm gonna spread
these out can you guys see this okay so
you'll look at these and just kind of
like I want you to doesn't actually
matter what card you're gonna pick
because we're not gonna do like I'm
gonna figure out what your card is but
if you like one just touch it slide it
out like I just picked this one so I
picked I picked gentleman claptrap arm
right so it's got the it's got the
monocle so you will pick it out will
look at it and then I'm gonna get a pen
out and we're gonna sign you're gonna
sign your card so it's I don't need to
know we'll all know what the card is but
yours will be the only one in the world
that looks like it because it's gonna
get signed okay so I'm gonna put that
one top so don't go to the top just
anywhere in the middle touch any card
you want that one okay that's the card
okay let me get these together and show
everybody what it is what is it oh it's
this is um this is pirate this is the
pirate clapped pirate claptrap arms okay
so let me I'm going to tell you where to
sound like a little X yeah and then so
sign it on the line
oh that's good
and do you usually sign your name like
this yeah exactly like that yeah like on
checks credit card receipts yeah okay
let's get rid of this let's uh let's
show everybody selfie this is what Danny
signature looks like all right I want
you to see this too you stay there I
want you to look at that if you
recognize it again okay help me out
we'll get the deck out we're gonna do
something impossible okay I'm gonna cut
right here drop it in facedown right put
it back in there it's lost in the deck
we're gonna shuffle it I'm gonna shuffle
it I want you to think of a number don't
say it yet take these think of a number
between 1 and 50 a random number okay
and we we didn't work anything out
before the show this is the forward even
coming up okay random number in fact if
you want you could even ask somebody
from the crowd but or you could pick
yourself you decide one in 50 we're
gonna need a number 34 47 47 you guys
now I want to give you an opportunity to
change your mind we can do 47 but we're
gonna count down and that's kind of a
big number
if you insist we'll do 47 but if you if
you want to pick a different one to save
everybody a little bit that's no big
deal
it's up to you I'm we're gonna count
down so we're gonna go through 47 it's
cool we can do it
this isn't me I'm a magician you guys
would you like to keep 47 or would you
like to change your mind I'm sorry she
doesn't want to change her mind
count one card face down on the table
face down on the table yeah
1 2 3 you do it 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24 25 26
27 28 29 30 31 32 33 34 35 36 37 38 39
40 41 42 43 44 45 46 top it was 47 right
let's get these out of the way that is
the 47th card put it on to the table
face down let's let it build I'll take
those
that's the 47th card you want to show
them show the card show them the card
this does not have your signatures you
guys this is supposed to happen because
I asked her what number to pick and
you've been holding that box that
gift-wrapped box from the beginning can
you open it don't get ahead of me open
it up
rip packaging off if you can it's really
professionally sealed I'll take that
yeah yeah get the cards out
got open those two there and also yeah
you can get rid of the clap shop cards
so you don't need those so yeah so let's
just get rid of those okay now we'll get
rid of those okay I don't want to touch
them count into my hands
47 cards you did this to yourself
you did this to yourself go ahead 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
19 20 21 22 23 24 25 26 27 28 29 30 31
32 33 34 35 36 37 38 39 40 41 42 43 44
45 46 stop take that card don't look at
it hold it against your chest that is
the 47th card give me the rest of these
give me the rest of these she has the
47th card you guys
that card was sealed with the rest of
these cards in plastic in a box sealed
in plastic wrapped as her birthday
present
he signed a card it's gone
she's got a card you don't believe it to
you did you look did you look
a miracle you guys a miracle
thank you so much you did a great job
thank you so much you did a great job
you know what I screwed up your both
your games so let's get you some fresh
copies happy birthday Danny happy
birthday darchele don't shower Danny
thank you guys and they'll help you're
not buying your way back sure